[Música]
momento de conocer las principales
noticias en materia económica en France
24 en español y es por eso que nos
acompaña Daniela hablando muy buenas
noches Dani Hola Santi muy buenas noches
Bueno vamos a comenzar en Estados Unidos
no la Corte Suprema tumbó un plan de Joe
biden van a condonar préstamos
académicos Claro pues entonces a primero
hacer como un contexto de lo que fue y
Es que desde la pandemia los préstamos
estudiantiles federales han estado
congelados el presidente quiso
complementarlo con una condonación de
entre 10.000 y 20 mil dólares
dependiendo del caso de cada estudiante
y eso fue lo que tumbó hoy la corte se
estima que unos 43 millones de
prestatarios Podrían haber visto
reducidos o borrados por completo los
saldos de sus préstamos pero ahora con
esta decisión deberán reanudar sus pagos
originales a partir de octubre la Casa
Blanca creó un plan de emergencia del
que no ha dado muchos detalles pero sí
que uno de los puntos principales es un
período de gracia de meses sin reportes
negativos a las centrales de riesgo para
quienes no paguen Esto no es lo mismo
que la pausa de préstamos estudiantiles
que ha estado vigente Durante los
últimos tres años los pagos mensuales
serán vencidos las facturas seguirán ahí
y se acumularán intereses y durante este
periodo si pueden pagar sus facturas
mensuales deberían hacerlo pero si no
pueden hacerlo y se atrasan en los pagos
esta vía de acceso elimina temporalmente
La amenaza de incumplimiento o de dañar
su historial de crédito lo que podría
perjudicar a los prestatarios en los
años venideros ahora una pregunta clave
que surge en este contexto es cómo van a
comenzar a prepararse no para poder
retomar sus pagos pues Santi ya expertos
han comenzado a dar Sus consejos el
primero es por supuesto Consultar con
asesores destinados exclusivamente para
estos efectos también aprovechar ese
beneficio que tienen actualmente hasta
último momento es decir no hacer pagos
anticipados Asimismo evaluar la
reestructuración de sus pagos Esta es
otra posibilidad que ofrecen O también
consultar si son elegibles para otro de
los varios planes de contonación de
condonación existentes por ejemplo hay
uno que dice que quienes trabajan o han
trabajado para una agencia gubernamental
o una organización sin fines de lucro
tienen derecho a un programa que ofrece
la condonación después de diez años de
pagos regulares Así que hay otras
opciones también que pueden consultar de
todas maneras consultarlo siempre con un
asesora claro se comienzan a verse bueno
las consecuencias de esta decisión de la
corte seguimos un rato más en Estados
Unidos Dani vamos ahora a Florida este
sábado va a entrar en vigor una ley
bastante polémica es muy polémica su
nombre original es
sb17-18 pero es más conocida en el
estado como la ley anti inmigrantes
promovida por el aspirante a la
candidatura presidencial republicana ron
de santis entre otros puntos esta ley
obliga a que las empresas con más de 25
empleados verifiquen la situación
migratoria de los mismos en un sistema
llamado
requiere que los hospitales soliciten el
estado migratorio al momento la admisión
y prohíbe que los gobiernos locales
expidan documentos de identificación a
personas indocumentadas así mismo
penaliza con hasta 15 años de prisión
aquí en transporte indocumentados a
Florida y a quienes los contraten bueno
y vamos ahora con un tema que tiene muy
atentos a los fanáticos del cine de las
series de la televisión estadounidense
porque el plazo para que los actores de
Hollywood negocien con los estudios está
por terminar pues vence precisamente la
medianoche de este viernes ese es el
límite para que el sindicato llamado
Zack abstra que representa unos 160.000
actores de Hollywood llegue a un acuerdo
con los estudios y evitar de esta manera
que se sumen a los guionistas que
recordemos este domingo inician su
tercer mes en cese de actividades el
motivo principal de su descontento tanto
de los guionistas como de los actores Es
que la Industria Del entretenimiento ha
cambiado drásticamente con el auge de la
transmisión de televisión y en la
aparición de nuevas tecnologías como por
ejemplo la Inteligencia artificial
generativa qué es lo que temen Pues que
pueda usarse para escribir guiones o
crear actores digitales
creo que sería bastante histórico tener
ambos sindicatos en huelga al mismo
tiempo ya sabes todas estas personas sin
trabajo y tratando de averiguar cómo
será el futuro de esa profesión en los
próximos 10 años creo que es
extremadamente poderoso y nos da mucha
influencia Pues el Santiago ahora vamos
a ver en el en el siguiente gráfico
Cuáles son esas producciones que se han
visto afectadas o que se van a ver
afectadas con esto pues inicialmente las
producciones con episodios que ya están
cancelados son de tunate show Jimmy
fallon de nbc con otros dos también
producciones de este canal CV esconderle
showwth Stephen colbert o hbo también
tiene algunas
algunas de sus capítulos parados por
culpa de esta huelga pero así mismo
también hay producciones que están en
pausa que son las más largas es decir
las de las películas ahí están varias de
Disney Plus están algunas de Netflix o
de todas estas compañías de streaming
que se están viendo afectadas con estas
huelgas
que tienen una audiencia enorme Daniela
Claro que sí y que lo que hay que decir
es que las producciones no solamente se
están parando en ese momento sino que a
futuro se va a ver más cuando empiecen a
no salir las películas Marvel por
ejemplo tiene una película parada por
culpa de esta huelga no las
consecuencias son enormes viendo algunas
de ellas son muchísimas las películas
así como decíamos famosísimas vamos con
la cifra del día Cuál es mire Santiago
esta cifra yo no sé si creerla o no
creerla pero ocurrió son 186 mil dólares
y ahora le cuento la historia es una
Ciudadana de la ciudad de granada que
acudió a la justicia española esto para
denunciar una estafa por ese valor
equivalente a unos 170 mil euros dicen
que un individuo que se hacía pasar por
el actor estadouniden Brad Pitt la
estafó por ese monto Con promesas de
amor que resultaron falsas su abogado
detalló que el año pasado ella se unió a
un club de Seguidores del artista en
Facebook y se contactó con otros
usuarios que le prometieron contactarse
directamente con el actor uno de ellos
le pidió altas sumas de dinero para
costear una visita a España Pues de pero
la denunciante decidió ir a la justicia
cuando se dio cuenta de que la cita no
terminaba de concretarse sin palabras
sin palabras incredulidad quizás veremos
sí lo extraño es que Brad Pitt necesite
que alguien le consigne dinero para
poder seguir No creo que tenga problemas
Muchísimas gracias por estar
completísima Crónica como siempre bueno
acá nos vemos en la siguiente hora
nuestra audiencia